security forces were called in on monday
night to surround the wealthy
neighborhood where the former president
of honduras lives
less than three weeks ago juan orlando
hernandez was in charge of the country
now the u.s is calling for his arrest
and extradition
prosecutors in new york have repeatedly
accused the former president of
involvement and drug trafficking
alleging his political rise was fueled
by drug profits
we've been calling for his arrest since
2015 when we denounced that the former
president was a drug trafficker corrupt
and associated with criminals
[Applause]
hernandez was president for eight years
u.s prosecutors have accused him of
receiving millions of dollars in
exchange for protecting drug shipments
through their country
the money was reportedly also used to
bribe politicians and help his political
career
[Music]
the former president has repeatedly
denied the allegations in an audio
recording on tuesday he said he's
willing to voluntarily turn himself in
i'm ready to collaborate and voluntarily
go to the authorities the moment the
supreme court judge is assigned to this
case so that i can face the situation
and defend myself accordingly
his legal team argues it will take its
direction from the supreme court of
honduras
and not from foreign countries
it's up to the executive power of the
nation we must wait for an independent
body of the state to make the
corresponding decisions
hernandez left office on january 27th
when the new president yamara castro was
sworn in on that same day he became
honduras's representative to the central
american parliament which oversees
political and commercial treaties across
the region
and as a member of that group his
lawyers argue the former president has
immunity from criminal prosecution
kazia lopez
al jazeera